now you can spice up your life and your
lunch lanetta offers a unique experience
for diners and joining us to tell us
more is their executive chef lanny chin
thank you for joining us thank you so
much for having us i have heard so many
good things about lanetta i've yet to go
it is in downtown summerland how long
have you guys been open for we've been
open for about six months now and the
menu just what i've seen it is
innovative it is delicious and it is fun
and now you guys are not only open for
dinner right yeah we also we're doing
lunch seven days a week now from 11 to
three except for sunday sundays we do
our brunch which is a whole different
animal in itself but we have we have
lunch every day um our big thing right
now is we have our power lunch uh thirty
dollars you get a uh appetizer you get
an entree and then you get a red velvet
churros to take back to your office or
you know wherever you need to go i love
it i mean what a deal on that let's talk
about the cuisine that you serve at
lanetta i'm looking at the first thing i
noticed on this table was this bowl
right here and i said is that poison and
you're like yes tell me tell me a little
bit about this so this is one of our
more popular lunch dishes and brunch as
a matter of fact this is our pasole
verde and then we have some fresh fried
chicharrones some tortillas a little bit
of cabbage to garnish and
we always top it with our pickled onions
which gives it like a nice little
vinegar pop but a little bit of heat um
love the hominy the tender pork it's
it's fantastic this just this dish right
here is my childhood so i was super
excited to see i have spoons so yeah oh
i'm going to try that but you mentioned
one of these dishes was your favorite
and i want to try that first and this
right here okay so i probably i eat this
five six times a week this is our shave
brussels salad so we have a little bit
of dried chili mangos
shaved brussels sprouts
watermelon radish and then we top it
with some
some toasted peanuts
and it has a white balsamic vinaigrette
so it's a little bit in here that's
that's a dried chili mango oh my
goodness that is delicious wow okay
let's talk about some of the other
things here what is this so this is our
this is our ceviche um this is on our
lunch menu as well as our dinner menu
and then two of my favorites we have our
cochinita pbl tacos and our barbacoa
tacos and then we do have those uh
featured on our happy hour as well as
our reverse happy hour every night as
well oh tell us a little bit we have a
lot of stuff going on yeah so um every
night we do reverse happy hour we have
um discounted tacos discounted beverages
and then one of our more popular dishes
our skirt steak is also on on both of
those menus as well now not only are you
well known for your delicious food but
let's talk about some of the fantastic
drinks
and you brought one for us
so this is our marg um this is
about two margaritas in one glass oh wow
so are you saying i should not like
choke this listen you can drink as much
as you want you know if i wasn't if i
wasn't working i probably would be
having one with you but my goodness um
so this is um yeah this is one of our
most popular cocktails we do have our
house mark in three different flavors we
have a we have a spicy one with a
cucumber one and and they're all
delicious fantastic yeah okay this
is being safe and you mentioned
you mentioned the churros so these are
red velvet churros and on the power
lunch we we box them up for you to take
to go and then we have a cream cheese
dipping sauce okay so like a cream
cheese frosting did you come up with
this entire menu i mean this is such an
innovative take on
latin inspired food i'm really loving
the
just the the changes and the upgrades
you made to it yeah so our um i work
with our chef at the location his name
is israel he's from mexico city super
passionate about
mexican flavors and this this menu is
definitely a collaboration of you know
his childhood flavors his nostalgia and
then a little bit of my thoughts on
changing presentations and
yeah it's it's been a great relationship
and i think we've come up with
definitely something special well it is
one of the hottest restaurants in town
and it is in downtown summerland now
open for lunches brunches you got to
check it out um
and yeah tell them tell them you want to
get the churros i'm telling you you
can't mix
just
this honestly it's all you need and then
put put a couple of these in there and
and you're good so i'm gonna enjoy this
here kendall i'll send it back to you
i'll see in a little while am i solo for
the rest of the show is that what's
gonna happen here
that looks great